hi everyone it's time for the Drew's
News podcast where we're serving up a
little pop culture some happy news a
dash of inspiration and an all-around
good time I love a good time today we're
covering everything from signs you're
dating a man child oh I love this story
so much to a Hollywood engagement 41
years in the making and we're doing it
with not one special guest but two Ria
and Fran are here who are better known
as chicks in the office how
oh thank you for having us are you
kidding I'm just lucky enough I got to
do your podcast I'm so excited we're
crossing over you know to cross over in
the Audrey yes Drew Barrymore we were
here to say my name but you know what I
mean yeah like we were shocked that you
were having us on here in this realm we
like to get into some news stories where
you hit the house we love the news yeah
King said they'll never not be news yep
and I just thought Gail you are so we
answered we entered the good space
thank God we can't do our show forever
all I do is like scroll for news and
stories yeah all right well the first
story is a love story 41 years in the
making so get this Blair Underwood the
actor just announced his engagement to
Josie heart they have been friends for
41 years and it turned out romantic
recently wow friends for that long 41
years then lovers and now engaged yeah
thoughts I love this because it reminds
me of the deals that I think I
definitely made with my closest guy
friends you did like when you're reading
18 and you're like you're like oh you're
down and out and maybe somebody just
dumped you and you're like oh God I'm
single and I this you feel hopeless
you're like 18 you feel hopeless it's
the silliest thing ever but in the long
run you you make that deal with your guy
friend where you're like oh in in 30
years and 40 years if we're both single
or if we're both divorced or one of
whatever the scenario is if we're both
single at that time we're gonna get
together yeah I feel like that's kind of
what this is I remember making those
deals when I was like 15 or 16 and being
like if I'm not married by 25 because
you always thought and you always picked
up you always thought that was like the
year that you were supposed to get
married yeah and you always said it to
the guy that was your your friend who
you also kind of like right like you
were really good friends yeah you were
like I'd like to end up like I don't
want to be with you now but I could see
it and then you get to 25 you're like
wait no
um like I'm yeah we're not getting
married yet I think I
unfortunately any guy I was really good
friends with it always led to a fling
and then the fling ruined the Friendship
that's my track record I don't know if
men and women can be friends I was
totally guilty of either initiating it
or just going with it or you know
falling into that pattern there was one
time I had a friend that was very good
friends with and he initiated it and I
thought oh well yeah maybe you're right
yeah we could have it all and then he
got weird and I was so mad at him for
ruining our friendship because our
friendship was so much more meaningful
than you know a stupid good fling I just
yeah and you hadn't even thought about
it until he brought it of course yeah I
I didn't and of course then I was also
like a bit heartbroken I was like oh no
like now I really like him because we
have as soon as they don't want you a
strong well we just had such a strong
Foundation I thought yeah why not right
just add water and like grow the miracle
Garden this is perfect yeah of course
he's smarter than I am I didn't see this
coming and then when he pulled away when
I went towards him I just thought
this is heartbreaking yeah oh it is the
classic question which you just said I
was very hot but I was so bad can you
have a friend and a friend
Harry Met Sally that there's no romantic
connection ever Underwood and Josie
heart where I guess I I'm desperate to
talk to him I want to be like where were
you 41 years ago did you guys ever make
a pact I know he was married for like 30
years
um so were they friends with like
subconscious seeds a lot of romantic
books that have a lot of stories like
this I feel like or it's like you never
thought about it before but then
something sparked it or you changed and
again maybe in a behavior way like that
person acts like who you've become so
you start to see them in a different
light thinking about a life with them
rather than just a friendship I mean I
I'm desperate to hear the details
because it is a beautiful rom-com um
yeah story it was just like an Instagram
caption throwing it out there oh by the
way I did this red carpet with who's now
my beautiful fiance my friend of 41
years but then you because you want to
know like if you asked him he'd probably
have nothing but nice things to say
about her now right but then throughout
all these years wouldn't his act had to
have been some options
hey were you thinking about this person
or you know there's a lot of questions
worried about which could be a no like
it could be like no it just kind of just
happened but then it could be a yes I
feel like there's so many different ways
it can go all I know is that this story
does not end here yeah I mean like I
need to stick with it and I kind of want
to understand it because it's a very
fascinating Dynamic most of all I'm very
happy for them I hope everyone's happy
I'm fascinated it's incredible to have
friends for 41 years
that's also it keeps a friend for 41
friends for 41 years it's pretty wild
yeah
it's pretty wild yes all right we're
gonna cut for a quick commercial and
then we will be right back
okay our next topic could be a rich
debate Jennifer Aniston recently
admitted to variety that she hates
social media she feels that the glamor
of Hollywood and actual movie stars are
fading as social media Rises thoughts
she's she's not wrong no but is it it
then it turns into a debate of well is
it a good thing or is it a bad thing
that social media has created all these
this new era of Fame and these new era
celebrities where it's not you know you
don't have that old Hollywood glamor of
just you just see them in the big
pictures and they're kind of untouchable
now celebrities especially social media
celebrities are very touchable reachable
you can contact them social media you
can talk to people so much someone said
because I was saying you know award
shows have really evolved into something
that I don't know we just had this
debate
people are and and someone said I think
it's social media yeah because you used
to see these people on this big night
all dressed up and it was like getting a
glimpse of a world that you didn't see
when the other side of an award show is
it's a very important thing in the
industry in the trajectory of someone's
work it's like a James Beard nomination
for a chef it's no different it's
everybody starts looking at you
differently you start to get different
work and it's an important catapult if
you are even nominated let alone win so
I'll never lose sight of that because I
know how the industry works as an actor
and a producer and director like when
people get nominated it matters and it
puts them in a different league with
people and whether they're able to ride
that out and carry the wave for a long
time is sort of up to their talents and
their choices and and everything but
um I was like God I never thought of how
social media and award shows like it did
take out this I I get to
break through and see this world you
just see it every day now I think even
not just social media but
Paparazzi phenomenon that happened 20
something 30 something years ago I think
that was as big of a shift as social
media and it's so different now because
Mega Glam right and and also the
conversation about who gets to go to the
award shows now it's really opened up
like it seems like if you're a tick
tocker you get to go and also whether
they diverse enough
so many different types of media are
being celebrated too it's not just like
hey we have
we have movies we have TV shows it's I
went to the wedding I'm so excited
exactly there's so much so many more
mediums now that give so many more
people the opportunity to walk those red
carpets and to be I wish there was more
of a I've never said this or thought
about it before but I wish there was
more of a a mixed bag I feel like the
way everybody also like diversely
diversifies how they process music and
television and art and culture and
sports and news like it would be fun to
see something I guess in a weird way
maybe like the People's Choice Awards I
don't know like I would love it to not
be so this is for sports this is for
movies this is for that it'd be fun to
celebrate a lot of different mediums and
the People's Choice we are two times
nominated
we have lost each time
about how the award shows are ready to
be nominated is important yes yes
definitely but yeah no it's Jennifer
Aniston really approaches this in such a
different way I don't think like so some
social media it's just not for some
people like social media is clearly not
for her she doesn't love it she doesn't
have to love it right and she doesn't
have to force her to love it yeah I
think people get upset when she says
things like this like she seems like
she's kind of looking up from an ivory
Tower of oh well I don't have all this
social media is ruining Hollywood it's
like that's how she feels about it and
we are going to continue I'm still gonna
love Jennifer Anderson
since Rachel first came out into the
morning show and everything she just did
phenomenal are you guys friends I know
her a little bit yeah and she's super
like I mean it's I it's so funny I'm
like even when I'm around her I'm like
it's Jennifer Aniston you know like some
people I don't know her well enough to
take like a little bit of that stigma
out of it because I am such a fan of
hers I think it's amazing I had said
that sentence of like if you get
opportunity and I guess depending on
your choices and your talent like how
long will you be able to carry out the
longevity of a job and she just
continues to rise it's like it's not
like she just sticks she keeps going up
you know it's interesting to hear it
from someone
who also has been so preyed upon and
throughout her career like whether she's
in a relationship or I mean she is a
sensation in her private life as well as
her public life I'm sure she's like why
would I willingly share anything yeah
it's interesting coming from her because
she's seen a lot of different angles but
I just love what she's putting out I
want more of it people are still talking
about her marriage from right years ago
yeah and what happened then so it's like
I would imagine she's probably trying to
keep some stuff private
um I will say
um the times I have hung out with her
I've had a really good time and
um she like throws down and she's super
fun yeah I could imagine yeah like she's
she's she is an absolute pleasure to
hang with she seems like she would be
really funny yeah and she's liquided
yeah and she's like keeps it real and
she's funny and she'll say things and
you're like oh cool like yeah right I
was thinking that but I didn't know you
were going to say it oh well you went
there cool like she's fun and groovy and
real and like yes witty and honest at
the end of the day she is cool enough to
say I don't need Instagram right I'll be
like you don't need Instagram she's not
gonna get upset with people upset with
her no like she's probably just gonna
keep it moving I don't know I think her
just being her has kept us all on a hook
so she just needs to keep uh being her
next story are you dating a man-child
well in style has a checklist for you so
that you can be sure I need a checklist
I'm really into this here is the list
some signs his home is a mess
he always has an excuse
constant financial problems
he can't handle criticism
and get this one he uses weaponized
incompetence to get you to do things for
him oh that old helpless act
um you know like literally acting like
he can't do something so you end up just
getting so tired that you do it yourself
thoughts man child this is very funny
and it's a funny list because when you
think of all those qualities
in one person it's like who's dating
that who's dating that guy if they have
all of those but I think I think a lot I
think a lot of guys have a lot of those
individually like maybe not the full man
child package but there were some of
those where you're like no yeah I've uh
I've I've definitely dealt with that but
not all of them so how bad is it but you
know it's like classic dating a mama's
boy or dating a man like it's very so
hot guys can be you know they can get
away with some stuff like you're so
attracted to them that you have some
horse blinders on certain behaviors
because you're Google gaga giddy for
that you don't want to end up feeling
like their mom like because then all of
a sudden you don't you don't want to
have sex with them after that well that
is the interesting point and you hit on
it because there is research emerging
that when you are dating a man-child in
air quotes your sexual desire lowers for
him the man-child phenomenon or
perceiving a partner as dependent
describes the blurring of the roles
between a partner and a child yes see
yeah and I think sometimes have very
caretate you if you have a very
caretaking quality about you you get
caught doing that and you don't even
realize
they're funny then you read that list
and you go uh-oh right and sometimes
they may even like have a job that's
actually really exciting and enticing
yeah but somehow still they're kind of
coddled and you know more immature in
their personal life so there can be some
things that also you're like I'm
attracted to them they have a great job
like you know he's funny and he makes me
laugh sweet too yeah and then you're
like oh he needs me right yeah and you
want to be needed and all of a sudden
you're in that Dynamic I think it all
all it takes though is being grossed out
by something
one time or more than one time
yeah but that's what it is like you get
the ick and then all of a sudden you're
like I'm not your mom like then it
clicks for you where you're like I've
been acting I like this is very healthy
that you have this mom meter yeah that
would work for you yes because I have no
gripes with my boyfriend now he's great
like I I think he's an angel and I I'm
not grossed out by him in any way shape
or form no x yet no no how long have you
been together
um I would say like we started dating in
like January okay great we live together
now oh so and it's been like we co-exist
very well I would say
wonderful it's lovely I have no gripes
with him of course you'd like get into
you know you bicker sometimes about
little things but to bickerson I'm not
grossed out by him by any means or his
living habits no icks yeah yes but I do
feel like and I why
I do feel like you could it could happen
and then once you get that wow it's
really hard to come back keep him on his
toes I guess to say like if you do these
things I'm gonna get the X so please
don't oh he knows that yeah
if you do these things and I start
feeling like I'm your mom I'm out I love
this so that's self-awareness that's
yeah like and again a boundary this is I
know this about myself this won't work
for me like these are all the things
I've learned through parenting that have
come to apply in wonderful areas of my
other life I'm like it is just a matter
of self-awareness and knowing what works
for you and what doesn't which again is
not selfish it is is literally like a
much more fun survival mechanism yeah
yeah there's always the not knowing
there's being lost and kind of hot lost
in the sauce
open like hey I don't like like I said
where I'm like hey if you start doing
this I'm out if you get those things out
there then they're probably if they
really love you and care about you
they're probably going to stay away from
from doing that it's setting up a
boundaries I know I've been living with
my boyfriend for a year and a half and
during the pandemic we kind of coexisted
as well because we just locked down in
the same place like I know that I have
some annoying habits that I'm like I
still haven't kicked those annoying
habits so I'm not gonna kick him too
much for his annoying habits because um
and whether that's like I'm a Serial I
come home or I'm on a trip or I I leave
my clothes on the floor like I just I
can't help it sometimes it takes me five
days to unpack my suitcase like I know
it can get to be I'll that that ominous
chair in the room where the clothes pile
up that's me and so when he's with the
bedroom chairs
when he leaves the wet towels all over
the apartment instead of hanging them up
which you know makes me like the steam
come out of my ears I'm like okay but I
still have that giant pile on the chair
so I'm gonna say once again you know
maybe pick up those towels
but maybe you can ask him like does the
suitcase bother you and if he's like no
you can say well find out what does and
then let me talk to you about it yeah
exactly tell me something
let's make a deal here because also
picking your battles and setting up
boundaries or learning as you're on the
job also which is okay and happens like
if you speak your truths you won't let
it fester and steam and blow up into
like some Avalanche of a resentment when
you could have just said
six months prior you know what your wet
towels there's something about it that's
I don't know because then the wet towel
fight turns into a fight about something
totally different yes yes and you're
making it like it's about the wet towels
but it's just not I could say every time
you clean up your wet towel I'll put on
a wet t-shirt contact
there you go that would work
by the way it works with everybody
all right we're gonna cut for a quick
commercial and then we will be right
back
welcome back uh you guys brought our
last story actually and I don't even
know what it is so I'm gonna get
surprised right now I'm very excited yes
so this has been a topic that's been
talked about on Tick Tock for the past
couple weeks Lily Rose Depp did an
interview
um about two weeks ago where she was
asked about you know nepotism and being
a nepotism baby and does she think it's
this new turn like not as not that it's
a new term but nepo baby has been used
people are using it a lot more and so
she was asked how she feels about being
put into that category
um and she kind of compared it to like
you know just because somebody's parent
was a doctor and then they become a
doctor people don't talk about it like
that you know so people didn't quite
agree with that analogy right because
being an actor or a mom because there's
like medical studies in school involved
or the profession is taken more
seriously but we would love your
thoughts on that because of course you
come from long line of I do
far dead because
there was nobody opening the door for me
unfortunately I I'm sure I would have I
don't know if I would have taken it or
not but I I think there's a lot of
children of right now too out in the
wild very it sounds silly to say but
it's like very in like everybody really
cares about these famous kids I have met
Lily Rose Depp only via Zoom she was an
early guest on this show
um and I will always feel so humbly
indebted to anyone who came on this show
it's like we weren't a success we were
upstart in a pandemic and our ratings
are good now they weren't great then
um and I just felt very grateful for
anyone who would take the time
like to come here like for me there was
no assumptions I always felt like no
one's ever gonna come and be on this
show so we'll have to find other ways to
make it and so when anybody did I felt
very very grateful the thing that really
blew my mind about her was how
articulate elegant eloquent mature
independent and wise she was she didn't
feel the need to discuss her parents she
wanted to do things on her own Merit she
wasn't talking about her family
um she actually wanted to be quite
discreet about it and keep it all about
her
um in a way that felt I think that
nepotism is not a bad thing it can be
very celebratory look these are my
parents this is my family yeah this is
the group of from which I come from and
look at what they've done so I think it
really if a door opens for you and if
you can are not up to that ask or you
are not competent or talented enough to
fulfill the the after you go through the
door you'll you'll find out pretty
quickly and it just feels like
um the the label's been thrown around a
lot and now these nepo babies are
continuing to be asked about it and now
I feel like everybody's getting a little
defensive it's like well I'm I'm working
so people are alive people are like just
acknowledge the the your parents but
it's then it's like they're they don't
feel like they need to do that I think
it's out of like an I I mean I I there
are probably some that have it for an I
want to make it on my own I don't want
to ride the coattails of I may come from
these people but I don't need to talk
about them all the time in order to
further my own success or career Lily
Rose Depp was so incredibly discreet
yeah she just wanted she was very open
to talking about things but I really got
the impression that she was a very
independent person who was proud of
where she comes from but didn't want to
make that the centerpiece to her own
ladder or success she wanted to do it on
her own so whatever doors were opened
she is not bragging or utilizing I feel
like she has
been also at it for like a decade right
now you know whether it's like starting
on a Chanel Runway to making multiple
movies and sustaining and still being
out there I don't think that has
anything to do with her parents anymore
that's all for her and maybe it's
important sometimes for people to also
keep their situation
private and sacred and that's their
choice if you are someone else and you
take a totally different tone you're
like this is my mom and I love her and
like I'm out on red carpets with her
like look at Goldie Hawn and Kate Hudson
right they're like the greatest love
story ever and you don't ever question
that and you're not calling her a nepo
baby yeah like because is it because
there's longevity there do they embrace
it publicly so it takes the stigma out
of it I think it's rather belittling and
demeaning to people to remind them that
they have an open door due to their
family and make them feel like they're
not worthy of being there that was going
to be my follow-up but I do think that
it's being asked too much to these kids
who are getting these opportunities
where now like every interview they do
they're being asked
about being a nepo baby which is using
probably why they start building up
walls and you know not wanting to open
themselves up to that conversation or
again some people are very upfront about
it like I love my mom and I love my dad
and this is awesome and so I think it's
that person's Comfort level it's that
person's Journey
um I would say ask yourself
how you would feel if you thought that
your work having the credit be given to
someone else or that you add doors open
it probably
wouldn't feel great yeah so maybe you
you might have some more self-awareness
that you're starting out by putting
people on the defense and I don't know
what kind of interview or conversation
you think you're going to have after
that but unless you're in a gotcha state
of mind that's not what you want for
your life it's not the energy you want
why have that kind of weird pissy energy
um just respect who wants to absolutely
be proud of who and where they come from
and those who want to keep it private
I don't think it's probably that much
different now than it was back in the
day we just didn't have social media and
reminders but there are lots of people
who come from famous families and went
on to like have careers but we didn't
experience it in this way we social
media has changed our perception of the
amount of things that occur and what
people have access to and everybody
feels like they have an opinion to
everything like I think that's where
people go wrong when they talk about
this it's like just because they had a
door open for them doesn't mean that
person's not talented or can't do what
they're doing it just means that maybe
they got to the front of the line a
little bit faster
I you know I think I I remember like
when I was a kid in the 70s and I had
that last name Barrymore and I I am sure
yeah it raised an eyebrow you know my
family was long gone at that point they
hadn't really been around in 20 or 30
years
um so it was sort of from the past
um but my family was you know they were
called the royal family they were a very
uh big part of the industry and going
from silent films to Takis so
I've really not thought about it because
I remember my mom always saying like it
didn't open any doors for us and she was
a single mom taking me on auditions a
lot of rejection a lot of filet
efficient
um and I started working when I was 11
months old and and maybe
maybe it was my name also a little bit
and who my dad was and the family he was
connected to she wanted to be an actress
she was working
she was doing jobs maybe something about
you know the genetics and the Alchemy
gave her ideas that might not have been
there otherwise or aspirations maybe she
thought like the name could open up the
door for us I wouldn't be surprised if
she did or maybe she felt a
responsibility to carry out the Legacy
whatever it is I'm so grateful I
wouldn't change a thing about my life I
feel a total responsibility to keep my
family's name on the up and up yeah I
want to honor that Legacy I'm one of the
last ones that it it it we you know we
don't have that many people furthering
our genetic Legacy so
just imagine if somebody was making you
feel inept
because of who your family is I don't
care where you're from or who you are
that's not going to feel good yeah and
you're just going to put that person in
an inferior defense mode so I don't know
what you think you're going to get out
of that right right
um right but um so having just met her
once I was swept away at what a mature
beautiful
lovely person she was I was really taken
by her I think she has that thing which
is also something people need credit for
wherever you come from whoever you are
if you have that spark that's the gift
and they think she has that spark yeah
yeah it's it's it's the hard work and
it's almost back to the social media
conversation of those kids immediately
being on social media gains a lot of
following because they're like oh well
this is the kid of blah blah blah blah
and so they without even really asking
they've got 100 of thousands if not
millions of followers doors open for
them who doesn't want to be on social
media how many millions of people follow
her oh it happened in two seconds yes
it's like 40. yeah she created her
Instagram to promote her hair products
her hair uh products
and 40 41 41. and she's like she had a
million followers within maybe minutes
yeah and nobody's unfollowing her yeah
after what she said I actually think
she's lovely on social media yeah I
don't think she over posts I think she
just doesn't like it but in a weird way
it's kind of like dating apps it's like
you cannot fight City Hall this is the
way of the world everybody's proceeding
accordingly so just yep take the stick
out of your butt and just Live and Let
Live man yeah Live and Let Live
definitely I love it I don't know if
that answers your question yeah that's a
long-winded one I think road to just be
kind and imagine if it was you how you
would feel and it is the way and the
phenomenon of the current modern world
that we live in but here we are doing a
podcast here we are hear me think about
it in a different way because we've been
talking about it and I think I was quick
to be judgmental about it and I'm kind
of putting myself more in those shoes
and not that I fully lived that because
it wasn't with wasn't with Fame but
there's always a little bit where people
like oh well she got that because of XYZ
because of what happened or yeah she
grew up or who she is or who her family
is or whatever yeah where you were
working the day yeah yeah
whatever however the alphabet goes
it's a fresh good nice way to cycle yeah
also you know everybody is just trying
to figure out their stuff you know we're
all wobbly calves Works in progress
trying to figure it out I bet most of
those people aren't comfortable in their
skin and it's awkward you know I grew up
in front of everyone but I never thought
about it because I thought that would
lead to an unhealthy ego but the rawness
and the vulnerability I really got but I
also saw that every kid in school was
going through that and people in a small
town anywhere like The Human Experience
is raw and vulnerable so just remember
that you know and everyone's just trying
to figure it out yep um and believe me
some people go out there with so much
bravado that I'm like Blown Away
wow okay you just all right you shot out
of a cannon good for you but it's just
been so much fun talking to you guys
like thank you for doing the podcast
thank you so much it really has been a
pleasure like a total imposter coming
into this world because I came in late
and there are plenty of podcasts
um I was excited for our angle that we
would have the anchor of stories I
always want to hear news like I loved
Bill Maher's new rules yeah like I don't
even know 15 years ago I would listen to
it on some audible platform and I would
giggle on the subway and I just love
anything pop culture and current and
debatable or interesting news so I was
excited that was what made me feel
comfortable going into it like we could
share stories and opinions but to be
with you guys who really started at the
beginning and I'm I'm really honored to
do this with you guys well it's it's
awesome and I just want to say it's very
cool that you entered the podcast space
and celebrate other podcasts
you're Drew Barrymore you could have so
many guests yeah and yeah
other podcasts I think is so cool and
it's very like seeing people like I said
in our space who we are friendly with
being like wow we get we're getting to
go on Drew Barrymore's podcast everyone
we were coming here that's exactly how I
feel about you so thank you and it's
true I would like to learn and
experience this with people who were
early to this space and found their way
with it and made it a success for other
people to have that Opera opportunity so
thank you guys thank you so much
seriously ladies all right well follow
the Drew's News podcast wherever you get
your podcast and if you like you know
you can just tell someone or share it
maybe you're texting with someone and
you could say like oh you have that long
drive definitely like listen to people
talking or you could say oh the regular
news you know is is really hard to get
through and you need like a heaping
scoop of ice cream on top of it well
then that's what we're here for it's
like listening to your friends yeah and
if you just want to hear something
happening in the world that you know uh
interests you I guess that's an
opportunity maybe you need to get so
distracted on the treadmill so you can
run that extra 10 miles and make the
time fly by well gosh I really hope we
can facilitate that for you and you eat
that big scoop of ice cream I guess
you're gonna have to go on that truck
and get that hot dog yeah and by the way
get that hot dog if you want to eat a
hot dog and listen to something while
you're eating and I I should listen to
this kind of news something's easy to
digest yes
this is not good I know
um so yeah this is a great accompaniment
to fatty foods a hot dog a corn dog a
filet of fish yes anything McDonald's
yeah anything comforting and delicious
um Pizza I'm gonna eat pizza tonight and
a hot dog
thank you guys thank you so much
[Music]
thank you